[Musik]
auf gar keinen fall
das ist auf jeden fall die richtige
richtung für uns also nur so
funktioniert halt wirtschaftlich und
natürlich erwarten wir die ganze zeit
drauf saß wieder getanzt werden darf so
[Musik]
also
mit 3g also ohne zweig sowie jetzt 30 30
tickets können wir dann verkaufen und
ohne können wir sowohl die bestuhlung
aufheben können wir
150 leute hereinlassen 160 170 sogar
genau und bestuhlt auch roland so also
das ist denn schon ja krasser
unterschied
die andere seite ist dass wir natürlich
auch den leuten die ja und jetzt in der
überzahl sind sozusagen die durch gift
sind den auch gerne ein stück normalität
zurück geben wollen und uns selbst auch
natürlich
[Musik]
die verantwortung seinen mitarbeitern
gegenüber wir selbst müssen irgendwie
eine miete zahlen und es geht
tatsächlich ums überleben unseres clubs
und wenn jemand sagt ja das ist unfair
für die anderen ja kann man so sehen
aber
wie gesagt wir haben keine wahl die
politik hat uns zwei optionen gegeben
mit der eine option haben wir eine
chance mit der anderen nicht mehr
es war für mich ziemlich perfide
irgendwie wir machen hier auf die erste
veranstaltung ich wollte arbeiten und
dann ist uns am gleichen tag aufgefallen
ich darf er gar nicht mal selbst
mitarbeiter dürfen dann nicht mehr in
dem selben räumlichkeiten wie die gäste
anwesend sein
[Musik]
auf gar keinen fall
punkt
weil es nicht sein darf dass ein
menschliches lebewesen vorteile hat wenn
es sich impft und genau andersrum
niemand darf gezwungen werden sich zu
impfen
[Musik]
ich war sofort da und dachte ja ist eine
gute sache wer sich darüber nachgedacht
was das eigentlich wirklich bedeutet es
grenzt menschen haus ist ganz menschen
aus die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
die sich nicht impfen lassen können wie
auch immer auf die gründe möchte ich
jetzt nicht näher eingehen aber diese
menschen werden einfach vom kulturellen
leben ausgeschlossen und ausgegrenzt
[Musik]
also kritisch sehe ist natürlich auch
und find's nicht schön leute
auszugrenzen aber ich habe einfach gar
keine andere wahl wenn ich
wirtschaftlich bestehen will mit dem
unternehmen
[Musik]